we're going to break into that now I'm
Kerry Johnson in Doha we're going to
cross over to see these pictures
breaking news now this rally in Paris
which is following the shooting deaths
of three people who mainly Kurdish
neighborhood on Friday now police have
arrested a 69 year old man they're
investigating whether the incident was
racially motivated
well we're going to uh speak with uh
Osama bin Javid in Paris now Osama
what's happening
thank you
we're having some difficulty getting
hold of our correspondent there as you
can understand the very
turbulent and tense
situation as we see these live
pictures
this is of course regarding this rally
that has been ongoing in Paris which
followed that that shooting death of
three people
in the uh mainly Kurdish neighborhood on
Friday this has created
severe tensions which are ongoing
in the France
capital
we understand that uh a 69 year old man
has been arrested who had apparently
been arrested before regarding a
separate
incident
and
it's unclear what further details we
have and why it was
that that man
had been released in that case
nonetheless you can see
an extremely tense situation as we look
at these
live pictures
from
the Associated Press News Agency and now
also
from the Reuters news agency as we take
in
some of this
atmosphere
[Applause]
well we understand we can now cross over
to our correspondent Osama bin jabbed in
Paris what can you tell us
protesters do fight too much away from
the Republic Plaza and they were met
with caused by the police tegaf shells
have been fired and now we can hear it
from the Sun that the leadership of this
protest is asking them to come back do
not be provoked by the police there is
going anger against the police where
these protesters are saying that the
police was ineffective when they came
under attack and now it is finding its
courage to charge at them and push them
back when they are protesting against
police ineffectiveness uh the crowds
have been Gathering here and swelling up
in the last few hours it's hundreds of
people have crowded here at the Republic
Square a chance there's something for
justice in the rain and they're calling
on the French authorities to do more to
try and get uh not just Justice for them
but better protection because they
believe that this was a deliberately
targeted attack at again heard the
curvish community here in Paris
Osama we can see these dramatic pictures
of the tear gas how are the authorities
reacting to this as far as you can tell
yes now
um as they move closer towards the
Republic Square the police have fired
more rounds of vehicles at them and we
can feel the effects of that here guys
now and they're retreating towards the
square as the police is pushing them
away from the Main Street
has anger been simmering within the
community there in any case even before
this incident
this is happening uh at the 10-year
anniversary of three Kurdish activists
who were killed
by the uh
one second let me get to the side
there's a lot of commotion here as the
police is moving people from the street
towards the square and pushing them
towards there but this has been a
similar situation for them and you can
feel why the anger has been growing in
in the last in the last 24 hours because
it's the same thing that the police have
not heeded to their cause of additional
security uh for the Kurdish Community
here for this particular Cultural Center
and they want the police to find out why
was this particular place attached the
protesters have been telling us that
there are multiple places if it was a
racist racist attack why them why not
another uh place that gets hackers goes
so it is a simmering situation here
where people are just not satisfied with
what they've been told by the
authorities they want to March forward
they do want the authorities to figure
out how angry they are about so far more
of them have been met the kids and they
are now seem to repeat towards the
square and it is now being filled with
tear gas will received the government
for its part has said that
it has been asking for more to be done
to protect communities
is that enough do you think in terms of
what these people and communities
feel is being done
clearly they're not convinced by those
statements by the police I mean here in
Ministry because they feel that they've
been the authorities have failed them uh
they want the authorities to keep their
calls and this is again not just aimed
at uh French authorities now the third
who who are here from Iraq from Syria
from Turkey uh have all got gathered
there and all of them have political
issues with them uh that they want to be
addressed by the French authorities many
of them are French Nationals when they
say that the government of France has
not been doing this part to not just
protect them but protect their interests
as well in their respective countries as
well so if you can imagine the Middle
East is is complicated Place uh these
this particular Community has been very
much involved in the fight against Isis
and they feel that they are not even
safe here in Sun and they're calling on
the French Authority see four that they
are safe they ensure that they are not
targeted places where they gather to
celebrate their diversity and culture do
not come under attack and this is being
in ongoing demand from the kurdist
community here in Paris
and in what seemed to be the Tipping
Point for this reaction what more are we
learning about the suspect
in the shooting
would this affect the 69 year old has
been involved in a number of the
racially motivated attacks six years ago
he threw racist slurs at people from
migrant communities just last year he
attacked a Sudanese migrant camps with
swords and injured three people that's
why he was he had to serve a jail
sentence for a year and a week after
this man was released uh he carried out
this attack in the entire neighborhood
against the Kurdish Community going in
attacking the cultural center first and
as people there chartered it down we
moved towards a restaurant and then to a
barber shop where eventually he was
overpowered by online we've been hearing
more reports of the words well prepared
he had in automatic weapons and also had
their animation at least three whole
magazines of around dozens of rounds
that we still had and he had he not be
stopped by people in that Community by
themselves he would have been able to
kill more people and that is something
that has made people angrier that the
police according to then took 40 minutes
to respond to their cause that there is
an active teaching going on they have to
overpower the attacker by themselves and
all that they do uh asking for the
police particularly against threats like
this have not been heard by them
does this kind of incident
and what's happened here clearly as a
result but reignite
issues of racism in France in general
not just amongst this community
but this is something that France has
been grappling with since 2015 if you
remember the whole migrant and Refugee
crisis and in the last few years as well
where the response according to many
migrant care has been heavy-handed by
authorities and they've not been given
what they have been calling for and is
being a Justice a justifiable place in
the community a community that will
welcome them and they've been met with
racist response from members of the
community and not enough protection by
the authorities and this is not just
limited response this is a phenomenon
that is the soliciting in many parts of
Europe since the refuses began and it's
not finds itself in the midst of
advising Far Right Movement as well as
sentiments at the exceed both from both
sides people who are at the receiving
end and others who feel that their
countries are being overtaken by
migrants which is not proven by facts
difficult to tell but from what you can
see on the ground there some might say
that the Authority's reaction has been
heavy-handed but but what would you say
from what you've seen
but this is it's been an accident
and you can imagine what the authorities
have agreed upon is they March from
their Cultural Center to The Republic
Square and this is where people gathered
and it was by and large very peaceful
since this morning it was only when uh
protesters decided that they have been
demand forward in the other joining
areas from the republics to show that
they are in numbers we saw the
authorities that they need to pay
attention not just when they were met by
roadblocks by this and he puts them back
and said and said to them that they are
only allowed to protests in the Republic
Square and are not allowed to March
forward but it is fluid situation an
active situation the attempt is running
High people are tangly and frustrated
and you can imagine these authorities
are responding to it as well as they can
indeed as you say a fluid situation as
we can see here I mean how shocked will
people in France be the general
population over these kinds of scenes in
in the capital city
but if you remember that
the tap on unions and and others even
during football matches the police had
to come out and call the either the
celebrations of the protest so it is not
uncommon for authorities to come out in
the state Council here
is designated to either put it together
and that is what we do now as well that
the authorities are now in full force I
can see policeman have achieved doubles
in their number I can see some firemen
arriving here
and they seem to be blockading this area
towards these were where they want
people and they're not allowing them to
go further they want them to stainless
Square uh continue with whatever they
demands are but not move towards other
areas of the capital
how does this
potentially play into their hands
of a right-wing brand of politics in
France in The Wider political sense that
does this and these kind of pictures
help them as such
it is a it's difficult to predict how
this will turn out for us
if you can appreciate that this is it's
no situation where the pictures there
was uh would be seen not just in France
lately but foreign
[Music]
it's it's very hard to gauge especially
as you say in this kind of
fluid situation but from what you have
seen does this represent or to what
degree does this represent
everyone in this community or is it just
a minority
of the community
well this is by and large right now it's
very specific group of a minority this
is the Kurdish minority so it feels
under threat which feels threatened by
the violence that has happened in the
last 24 hours and it is not helping the
fair Target solution responded so far
there were people who who were OBS with
the heavy-handed police response
according to them last night and this is
what they're saying now is that that the
police is not being fair in listening to
their calls and allowing them to express
themselves and their demanding The
Authority is not just give them to
provide them Justice and it's also had
the right to be able to express
themselves in the way they want to
clearly that does not need to be the
same from the authorities
you of course would have spoken to
some of the people here beforehand how
much did you get the sense that
something may happen that something may
build up and reach this kind of Tipping
Point
it
come out and told them they I do not
think that any of them were expecting
that the police is going to stop them in
full force because they thought that
they have the right to come out and
receive an obviously some sort of
permission to mark from their Cultural
Center towards the Republic Square and
now they seem to be moving back into
that street we're looking for that
problem for numbers and we can see
organizers have asking people to follow
them in that direction and more to your
gas shells are being fired by the police
as they are being met with the sport and
this is something which is not helping
matters because as I said earlier these
protesters have these things that where
was the police when they came into
attacks where was it when they
overpowered the attacker and why is it
dealing with them respectful
and clearly it's likely that
that people here and
Security Forces too will be injured in
this we can see people ripping up
stones and uh and the like and the
tarmac to
to throw at security forces who are
responding with tear gas
how bad can this get it it really does
look quite shocking
but it is coming to a head right now
where protesters are not backing down
first before they move on of that street
and now uh they were pushed back and
once again uh they're being asked to go
back here in numbers towards that
position off the police which is pushing
them back uh because not allowing them
to go through and this is something
I advice they escalate things further
because if the police says they cannot
move and they continue to go to a this
particular Avenue uh they are going to
be stopped and and as we've been being
improving to people their temperature
will run High people are in High Spirit
and there's dominant here over there
families and their children to express
solidarity and you can imagine there's
going to be more anger more frustration
from these people who clearly are not
convinced by the response from The
Authority so far
foreign
stay safe we'll come back to
a little later
now we're going to speak to yes luatia
political analyst and civil rights
activist now he's in Paris live for us
if you can
hear me here what do you make of these
continuing scenes
uh well we have to understand that
France has been under tremendous social
pressure for the past five to ten years
at the presidency of Emmanuel macron has
further exacerbated social tensions and
scenes like this one are not a surprise
given how tense the situation is in
France and the fact that the attack was
carried in broad daylight in Paris
despite France having passed the most
stringent counter-terrorism laws in the
past 20 years to no avail and on top of
it the government does not want to
acknowledge that this is in fact a
terrorist attack being carried by a
person who adheres to far right ideas
the same idea that have been promoted by
Emmanuel macron for the past five years
the further
a provocation of the macro government
was to in fact ascending massive police
presence as people tried to gather in
the aftermath of the attack to at least
commemorate the death of a three Kurdish
persons
the government though would say that it
has been pushing on asking for more to
be done to protect the community why has
that not been enough then
well actually the answer is in your
question sir because the government
passed the so-called
domestic security law that has made the
uh a set of emergency permanent which
means now the executive branch of power
can arrest people without going before
the Judiciary with the they passed in
2014 the law allowing Mass surveillance
in the name of preventing these attacks
yet these attacks keep happening and the
government is directly responsible not
only for these uh these abusive laws
these repressive law that obviously make
no have no results but also for peddling
the far right rhetoric towards
foreigners we have to remember the two
years for the passage of the Elta
separatism law the fact that Gerard
dharmana even called Marine Le Pen two
lenient or too soft on Islam and that is
all in during his presidential
re-election campaign made sure that Mary
Le Pen gets a platform in order for him
to confront her on identity issues and
not confront jealous menosho on social
issues so we can be surprised by the
amount of uh political of anger in the
streets at the same time if we just step
back and look at the past five to six
years there is absolutely no surprise
and unfortunately in the country that
saw the yellow best movement any event
that can trigger such massive
demonstrations and again this is a dire
indictment of the macro approach towards
the terrorism because the person who
carried these attacks was known by the
Judiciary was known by domestic
intelligence yet he was allowed to run
loose in the street and how can the
government act as if they were surprised
that said how how does the general
public in France see this does this play
into the hands as it were of a
right-wing agenda and brand of of
politics in the country in a in a wider
political sense
we cannot speak of now a French public
opinion because there is the
bed far right ideology
in the mainstream media the
hyperconcentration of media ownership in
the hands of people who are pushing this
far right richwick the the likes of
Versa bolore and his media network with
a sinus that gave a platform for people
like uh Eric zemur and there is also
another part of French public opinion
that is calling this a terrorist attack
and is asking for this to be to be dealt
with as a search and now the
polarization of French society that has
been exacerbated under Emmanuel macron
is taking us into a dead end either we
have you know the normalization of the
far right thanks to Emmanuel macron or
we have an opposition to it that the
macron government does not want to
listen to and when people say that
France is heavily polarized they also
have in mind the fact that domestic
intelligence has been warning the
government for years that the far right
it's Terror network is growing and that
the Republic of which we can public
discourse is giving them a sense of
impunity we should not forget the 2019
year that we saw a series of far-right
attacks being thwarted and the fact that
we have media appendix operating in mass
in in major newspapers like Le Figaro I
can quote for example a person like
Yvonne or you fall who wrote a famous
book or inFAMOUS book speaking of quote
unquote the the coming civil war so this
is what is being peddled right now in
the public debate unfortunately our
policy makers not only you know promote
these ideas but they also transform them
into policies as we saw it within
multiple counter-terrorism laws
targeting minorities and at the same
time the government passing legislation
specifically targeting communities and
most most specifically the Muslim
Community and you see that this
siding with this ideology by the
government to this day and at least 24
hours later they still cannot deal with
this as a terrorist attack it is a
terrorist attack the person attacked a
refugee camp just last year he said he
was fed up with foreigners yet the
government did not lock him up or they
did and released him in opposition to
that if you take out how you know
foreigners are being treated especially
refugees and then people of a Muslim
descent and even French Muslims you see
that they are double standards you can
me you can be a white person promoting
far-right ideology on prime time in the
media that is seen as you know a freedom
of speech but when people oppose that
they are seen as radical leftists or a
separatists this is really a serious
issue because again the government being
unprepared for it means that their
parallel towards the Muslims has allowed
this terrorist attack to be carried and
furthermore has shown that the
government does not listen to domestic
intelligence when they say now the
far-right networks are more stronger
than ever and this is not a French
tendency the same is applied in Sweden
in Germany in Italy and across the
European Union and so far we do not see
policy makers standing up to that and
taking the matter seriously given what
you say then why has the left
not managed to combat this over the last
few years and push its own agenda
well you again unfortunately sir the
answer is in your question the left is
notorious for each internal you know a
strife and their you know their internal
Wars between various political parties
we see that the party or the movement
that supposedly was to represent the
left at the policy level and push
towards a more left-leaning uh policy
making uh jealous party is now imploding
before our eyes they managed to score to
make it to have high scores in the
presidential and the legislative
elections but to this day for decades
they have been unable to transform these
public postures into effective policy
making and yes you are definitely right
the left has been unable to challenge
the government on this a particular
field it is not enough to say macron is
you know supporting far right ideology
what is the alternative offer and so far
I do understand the voters when they
look at uh jealous party La France and
sumizo unsubmissive France the green
party the Socialist Party or the
Communist Party Unfortunately they lack
The credibility and they have failed to
position themselves as a concrete
alternative that people can decide to
vote for and that's exactly what Macomb
is doing he's making sure that he
remains the party capable of governing
the country while the left is you know
going from one Civil War into the other
and then being unable to push for a more
or for for more uh um for more just
policies and that is the responsibility
okay political analysts and civil rights
activist yasiloati stay with us if you
will we're just going to cross over
again to our correspondent Osama bin
jabbing in Paris so what can you see
there summer what's happening